trying to find a public bathroom in New
York City it can be an absolute absolute
retch of shitshow
yeah never in my life have I seen a
clean public bathroom in New York City
and it's really really frustrating if
you really have to go
I have to pee all the time when it comes
to bathrooms for me I can be a little
bougie I don't have porta potti
standards like Chris I've been around
New York City and thought my insides are
gonna explode a nice public bathroom in
New York is like the golden ticket to
Willy Wonka's chocolate factory well so
I'm gonna go on this quest with Chelsea
and Chris we're gonna do all the dirty
work so you don't have to we are going
to find the best public restroom in New
York City
come in all right so our first step is
gonna be plotting out this entire
adventure
[Music]
I actually saw this curved article that
lifted like a ton of great bathrooms
apparently and they even ranked up yeah
for our convenience
maybe we could start right up here and
then which is like way down I think we
can find a few more extra places by
talking some people around the office
where should we be going
probably the Time Warner Center it's not
a bad bathroom it yeah we'll put it on
the list I always pee on the High Line
it's like a five bathroom but it's a
public one looking at all this together
it's gonna be a really tight schedule to
try and fit all this in in one day we're
dumb a planning we got the bathrooms we
want to go into we're ready I think it's
time to go out and drink appeal city
ready for us today is the day we've done
all our research we've done all our
planning it's time to hit New York City
and we're gonna find the best public
bathroom we're gonna rate it from one to
ten one being the worst ten being the
best push Lisbon to the end of the day
we're gonna tally up the scores and find
out what is the best of the best of
public bathrooms in New York City but
first we got to fuel up we're going to
get coffee we're going to get water time
to fill those bladders so we can pee all
over this city
I'm gonna have to be soon here we are we
are at her first stop on our journey
across Manhattan we're at the Lincoln
Center we all really have to pee I
excited to be super fancy because this
is where our opera is fancy look at that
grass on the wait time in factories we
have to wait is it everybody wait in
line for that one on the first floor
like an idiot so I'm going to the second
floor
oh there's a urinal in here I mean it's
pretty pretty clean it's very private
definitely not like disgusting and gross
I don't think it's gonna be the best
bathroom that we see today I don't know
if it'll be in my top five whoa full
disclosure I know the next bathroom
we're going to I know that it's good PSD
yeah you got PhD and toilets but
honestly alright so we're here at the
time 1 and center right across the
street from Trump right across Turkey
from pull up the circle I don't want to
give too much away but you can't expect
cuddliness and let's roll so we're
inside it's so nice it's fancy she's
gliding around on the marble floors
[Music]
check out I feel like I've been walking
for three goddamn miles in this place
it's like a damn maze in here I'll give
you guys a little walking tour nice tan
pools we got one two three four five
stole homeliness wasn't as good but it's
a really big bathroom so ever seen a lot
of people so I could have just caught it
on a different day I feel like I can
only take off like a half weight better
guys there was a goddamn TV in the
mirror big bonus points on there she is
thoughts feelings right good [ __ ]
straight up the back good [ __ ] this
bathroom made me feel steam I'll be bold
and say it exceeded my expectations this
is a weird project now let's go to the
next
[Music]
that's gonna be me in ten minutes
walking
[Music]
all right we're gonna go into maybe the
fancy is one of the day Bergdorf Goodman
this one's legitimately scary I think
it's fine to go into fancy stores
whatever like not fancy clothing because
it's like Power Move I don't care but
then I show up and I'm like I care
definitely luxury so this phantom has
very secluded stalls which is very close
the policy is top-notch
[Music]
pretty small we're going up we're trying
to get out but we don't know how to get
up Omaha was great I think that the
mirrors will awesome battles awesome I
liked it I would be there again no for
me
magnificent
let's go I hate this part of the city
we're losing the steam get real hot so
we're here at the citizens in hotels
right around the corner from Times
Square it's got like a sexy vibe on the
outside of into that I'm looking for a
sexy pee experience
[Music]
whoa this is like repeating I thought
this was a single bathroom standing
outside the whole time waiting for her
to come look that's the same lady that's
on the door
seven total it's not what I'm adding so
I have to touch it
I guess that's how men used to look
pretty good I think is an understatement
I was super into that bathroom yeah
sorry I liked it I don't know if it'll
be my favorite but I like toilets
immaculate
I like the seclusion of these we saw
nobody there great you're gonna climb
the ranks
[Music]
why apart man we've been it we're tight
as hell really there was like a like a
quarter million dollar renovation
recently so we'll see you click with the
money where the P alright let's go pick
him on the trail I think I found
something that could be a bathroom we
found it it kind of looks like the to
one of the worst parts of going to the
woman's bathroom
the line for the woman's bathroom
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Jade got in trouble and got asked to
leave philosophy breath best public park
bathroom I've ever seen in my entire
life or degree there's only two stalls
in the women's one I'm like craving a
cup of tea like a spot of tea after
coming out of that super clean it was
someone cleaning right after I came off
the bathroom you're like a lovely
[Music]
hydrate hydrate
[Music]
we are on the High Line which is a
renovated it used to be abandoned
railroad track goes from 14 to 34th
Street and it's really cool they have
like a lot of pop-up shows get to be in
[Applause]
[Music]
No
pretty
oh really
we seem to be like a little bit all over
the spectrum white I was pleasantly
surprised you I was pleasantly upset
yeah I think it depends on the stall we
got our sanity is like yes
Titus even toilets necessary every time
I'm not hearing I told you we're going
insane thank god this video is almost
done we're almost done
the Sun is literally setting we have
spent an entire day peeing around New
York City we have one left
[Music]
guys we made it this is beautiful it's a
lot calmer than what the outside would
entail let's say freakin another good
note today let's put our hands on one
more time
[Music]
let's be I was starting to get nervous
that I was gonna take a really long time
to find the bathrooms but we found them
signage is a plenty
as far as the cleanliness goes I'm gonna
have to take a point from that little
tissue right there
[Music]
one thing I would says pretty awesome
though is little waiting room right
outside the bathrooms that area is
really cool it has little vending
machines and stuff how do you feel no
super clean from what I saw there was
like a place to rest and get snack this
place looks so beautiful out here I felt
like the bathroom should have definitely
held up to that standard as well
I hate silver song so much salsa no it
just it just makes it look attractive
we're gonna give some quick feedback on
the scores and why we gave each one
we're gonna add them up and then we're
just going to figure out who won
[Music]
folks at home my folks here the scores
are in and underlying in third place
with the score of twenty four point four
out of 30 in third place we have Bryant
Park
the strong runs for Brian Fargo know
Jane's probably a little bitter about
that second place with a score of twenty
four point five a tenth more we have the
World Trade Center transportation my
stallion I'm sure this will come as no
surprise but with a top score of twenty
six point five out of 30 which is super
strong taking over the gold citizen we
did it you guys we found that the best
public bathroom in New York City citizen
and they actually know so Wow just go
talk to the ladies initially you where
the toilets are
[Music]